مازلنا بانتظاري تقديمي المساعدات الى
الشمال الغربي والوقوف على حجم الاحتياجات
وفي فتره
الظهر كنت قد اجتمعت مع المسؤولين في
سوريا الذين قرروا ان يقوموا بفتح اعداد
متزايده من الحدود مره اخرى منظمه الصحه
العالميه ملتزمه بدعم الشعب السوري الان
خلال الايام والاشهر القادمه من اجل
معالجه مخلفته هذه الكارثه
وتقديم كافه اوجه المساعده للشعب السوري
شكرا دكتور تدرس
كما هو معتاد ان كان لديكم اي اسئله نرجو
منكم برفع الايدي
ونرجو منكم ان تعرفوا عن انفسكم عند طرح
السؤال ولكل منكم ان يطرح سؤالا واحدا فقط
اولا سوف نبدا من
شكرا جزيلا على تلقي سؤالي
كنا قد سمعنا ان عدد الوفيات قد تجاوز 30
الف وكنا قد راينا حجم الدمك ما هو
تقديراتكم الى الاشياء التي
ان مازلتم تبحثون عنها ولاسيا ما في ظل
وجود اعداد كبيره من الضحايا
تحت الردم اذا ما كان لديكم ايضا اي
تقديرات في سوريا اذا ما كانت خاصه ان
الامور اكثر صعوبه في في اطار المساعدات
وافتقاري الاليات والمعدات المطلوبه
شكرا
جزيلا على سؤالك
لا اعتقد باننا نستطيع ان نقدم اي اعداد
دقيقه في هذه المرحله
عن عدد الوفيات وما زلنا بانتظاري
التقديرات
من قبل كل دولتين
وحتى اللحظه فان عدد الوفيات الذي ذكر
عنها في سوريا حوالي اربعه الاف بالاضافه
الى
عشرات الالاف من الاصابات نعلم ان هذه
الارقام مرجحه للصعود الى حين ان تتاح لنا
قدره الوصول الى الاماكن
المنكوبه في الايام القليله القادمه
بحيث يتسنى لنا تقييم الموقف
لكن كل ما اقوله بان هذه الارقام المتوفره
لدينا مرجحه للصعود
السؤال الثاني من
يوري اي اي
صباح الخير
في عمليات الاغاثه السوريه في المناطق
الواقعه في الشمال السوري لان لان الجنود
الروس كانوا
قد تركوا تلك المواقع فهل هناك اي تعاون
معهم
شكرا على طرح السؤال
من الضروري ان ندرك
ان هذه العمليات تدار من قبل مكتب تنسيق
المساعدات الانسانيه التابعه للامم
المتحده
ويتم تنسيق مع كافه الاطراف من قبل
هذه هذا المكتب الذي يتصل
وينصق بك مع كافه الاطراف اذا
منظمه الصحه العالميه هي ليست الجهه التي
تجري تلك المناقشات مع روسيا او غيرها او
اي طرف ثالث
قال لي اذكر من هم موجودين
معنا لطرح اسئله عبر الانترنت
ارجو منك ان تفتح المايكروفون
محمد منصور من الشرق نيوز او الشرق
للاخبار اود ان اسال عن اوجه الاختلاف بين
الاوضاع
في سوريا وتركيا
من حيث عدد الوفيات
كما تعلم اننا موجودون حاليا في سوريا
[موسيقى]
الفرق بين تركيا وسوريا
هل لك ان تكرر
ما هي الفوارق التي تشير اليها
لقد لم نسمع الجزئيه الاخيره من سؤالك
[موسيقى]
يبقى
قد يكونوا من الصعب احيانا ان يتم اعطاء
تقديرات صحيحه في ظل ظروفي
الزلزال الكارثي
وتحديد
التقديرات الدقيقه في كل في منطقه بعينها
لكننا نعمل على تقديم
المساعده
ونشري فرق الانقاذ والبحث
لتامين المواد الغذائيه والمساعدات الطبيه
وغيرها
من المؤكد ان اثر هذا الزلزال كان كبيرا
وخلف اثرا لا يقل فارقا بين المناطق
الريفيه والمناطق الحضريه
ونعلم ان المناطق الريفيه قد تكون لا تحظى
بنفس الخدمات مثل المناطق الحضريه في
سوريا
[موسيقى]
لكننا راينا انتشارا كبيرا لفرق الانقاذ
والبحث التي تعمل على
تامين متطلباتي الناس هناك كما هو الحال
في كافه الازمات
ويمكننا ان نلتقي
الدروس مما حدث من هذه الكارثه التي ضربت
تركيا على وجه التحديد
[موسيقى]
ولو كانت قد اتيحت فرق الانقاذ والبحث
والمعدات الثقيله في سوريا لعلها لكانت
تساهم بدور
اسرع في
معرفه مواقع
العالقين تحت الانقاد
لكن حتى فرق الانقاذ لا تستطيع ان تقوم
بالعمل على اكمل وجه لم تتوفر المعدات
والاليات المطلوبه والحديثه
لدى
[موسيقى]
تعمل
اجهزتي الدفاع المدني على
الانتقال عبر المناطق المنكوبه
والمخاوف الاساسيه الان
تكمن في الاوبئه الصحيه التي قد تنجم عن
تلك الماساه
سؤال من بي بي سي
ريح
شكرا جزيلا
وتنتظرون بزيارتكم
للشمال السوري وبالاضافه الى ذلك منذ ان
ضرب هذا الزلزال كان هناك اي عمليات تسليم
للمساعدات عبر الحدود ام نفس الموقف
القديم لاننا ما نعلمه حتى اللحظه بانه لم
يتم
توزيعها بصوره او كامله
لا لا يوجد
اي عمليات تسليم للمواد الاغاثيه عبر
الحدود
وما زلنا نناقش ونتفاوض في هذا الامر مع
الحكومه السوريه
ومن خلال
منظومه الامم المتحده نسعى لايجاد
طريقه يمكن من خلالها تقديم المساعدات عبر
الحدود
وان يكون هذا الخيار
هو الذي يمكن الاعتماد عليه بحيث يمكن
ايصال المساعدات
وكما قال الدكتور تدرس ان نعمل مع شركائنا
من اجل
الانطلاق بتقديم هذه المساعدات عبر الحدود
باسرع ما يمكن
شكرا على السؤال
اننا
على وشك الانتقال لمرحله تقديم المساعدات
في اي مرحله الان
بروايه وننتظر
لنسمع من الطرف الاخر
الرد وبمجرد حصول ذلك سوف ننتقل الى
الشمال الغربي
اننا بحاجه لقدره الوصول كبيره
لمناطق الشمال الغربي
ات قدره وصول عبر الخطوط
وعبر الحدود
ندرك حجم صعوبات التي تعترضنا
من حيث قدره الوصول للقوافل
الى هناك
والانتقال في الى الوجهات المطلوبه
اود ان اضيف
ان
المناطق ان الاوضاع قد تكون اكثر صعبا في
الشمال الغربي وفي حلب
سمعنا عن ان هناك شحنات تصل يصل وزنها الى
سبعه ملايين طن بالاضافه الى بعض المنتجات
التي لم
تبلغ وجهتها في الشمال
الغربي
سؤال
وكما ذكر
الدفتر مايكل الناس لتامين قدره الوصول
الى المناطق التي يوجد فيها
اناس بالامس الحاجه للمساعده